today we're creating a smash man playing
a game to 100 points building a domino
out of rackets and more let's get into
it so the one who gets most swipes under
the ball wins so the official height
it's exactly my shoulder level ready
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven
that worked quite well
all right that's good plus you're doing
that do you want a jumping next
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve Thirty forty fifty six
fifteen
he's lifting a little bit I I have a
different tactic
oh you have a different grip how did you
have it
three four six eight ten
it's a new record it looks like it
shouldn't be possible to do this yeah I
was thinking like the last fight while
we're already like it can't be possible
to still keep going well that was a fun
game Let's create the smash man we're
gonna need a couple of Smash rackets out
of here not probably very enjoyable we
are creating a monster oh yeah I get
some skin in there you can scare some
crows smash man can do many things but
tying up his own shorts not one of them
we happen to have an offer on our web
store where you get one of these smash
rackets a racket case and boards for
59.90 so go and check it out yeah don't
tape his mouth there is still some
engraved rackets left so be quick to get
one not on the skin what wouldn't you do
for beauty
the legendary smash helmet is being
forged the Smashing ritual
[Music]
who dares to challenge the smash man I
shouldn't say his mission was to be a
human shield
it's the human blocking War
it's good that you had some Shield there
kind of the smart man
weakening my shield
I'm half smash man but we can live with
that
you really have to work with the hips on
that one
I don't know what part of the smash man
it hit but it came on
get your smash racket from pongfinity
dot store I got the smash logo
[Music]
match to 100 points the longer the rally
gets the more points you get air Mill
with the custom scoreboard
I'm energized
eight points
one point for us
I I knew like I shouldn't play this for
long rallies
13 points for that okay I need to get
some points now also
Five Points
that's a huge one
[Music]
we're not we're not that far from 100
like two points
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't get passive
no you have to get exactly 100.
I have to start counting
[Music]
okay I need Five Points serve receive
Loop finish
[Applause]
do your best for him to make the service
mistake please play
okay
[Music]
and it actually doesn't make too much of
a difference but it's mentally very
different it was pretty fun
maybe the next one is to 1 000 points
who knows that's it it's the winning
setup what did you actually like
calculate it well I don't have to
calculate anything it's gonna fail fail
either way as long as I've been watching
these competitions Emil and Otto have
won the most yeah I never win
so the first one to knock over there
Domino and get the ball into the cop
wins Ready Set Go
that's gonna work
round two to two I have a feeling I'm
just gonna get this Ready set go
all right it's not going it's not going
if you make this we're gonna call this
the German yes go
foreign
now I know the exact spot to get the uh
to get it right next time Ready Set Go
[Applause]
sh
I got it
okay how is that possible it went from
Mika's uh racket I got it I told you I
told you last after last one that I'll
get it the next one and it was the
perfect ping pong volleyball three
touches let's try it out let's go to
purple come on family
[Music]
oh
nice my round the net wasn't enough
[Music]
it was out by this month the rules they
work
[Music]
I was actually like what should I do I I
thought we were spinning area here like
foreign
[Music]
thank you sorry
well that was in the final one thanks
that was actually a good spot